[Music]
you don't think I'm strong enough I
don't know if you're cruel enough oh man
don't have to be cruel in the themes of
the film you said your twins live by
night and they're like gangsters very
total
gangsters these kids are like up at
night and like one is it more into
talking Spanish the other one is
expressing himself for in English so
what is like not kidding okay and the
other was like I don't wanna when you
tell them like it's time to go to sleep
and they're both yelling at you all
these things and when they start
fighting they just look like two lads in
a pub fighting over like the wrong girl
dude Ana's just vicious and you're like
you guys are only two this is horrible
I mean goodness knows what it's very
like later I know I think it's gonna get
better I have thought we have to have
that approach please please we have to
have hope
how was the holidays for you are they
are they aware like Chris celebrating
Christmas with all the presents and the
lights all and stuff really aware of
everything that's going on and they have
an idea but their approach is very
musical so it's through songs that you
get to get them to understand like who
Santa Claus is and everything but and
then my husband and I have another year
until they're three I think we have this
year to decide what kind of Christmas we
need to create and what and follow that
tradition indefinitely for our family
because we we don't want to deprive um
each other's respective backgrounds to
how we celebrated Christmas as kids
you
[Music]